à serge hoareau 40 devant maire de la
commune de petite île président de
l'association des maires de la réunion
et premier vice-président au conseil
départemental de la réunion
le menton 22 pour moi est un canton en
qui correspond bien à ma philosophie on
est en pleine ruralité ce qui fait un
peu notre lien entre la partie de saint
joseph la partie ouest de saint joseph
qui fait partie du canton la partie s de
saint-pierre et l'ensemble du territoire
de la commune de petite île et même si
on est assis sur trois communes il y à
cette homogénéité je dirais de
territoire à travers ce lien fort notre
identité très forte qu'est la ruralité
le quand on mène deux mâconnais les
mêmes problématiques que l'ensemble des
cantons de la réunion et nous comptons
beaucoup sur l'intervention du
département aussi bien traverser
politique d'action sociale l'aide
sociale à l'enfance être social en
direction des personnes âgées des
personnes porteuses d'un handicap
l'insertion pour notre jeunesse
l'accompagnement notre jeunesse sur qui
nous voulons miser un investissement
essentiel pour l'avenir et le devenir de
notre belle île et bien évidemment
continuer à amener les actions sur les
routes du canton 22 sur l'accompagnement
des casernes de sapeurs pompiers du
canton 22 et puis enfin et là c'est un
petit peu je dirais le coeur qui parle
donc l'intervention en direction du
monde agricole puisque je dirais c'est
cette délégation qui est la mienne ici
au département en tant que premier vice
président et je suis très heureux de
pouvoir continuer la mission que j'avais
démarré en 2015 et poursuivre auprès du
monde agricole pour soutenir
l'agriculture réunionnaise dans son
ensemble
être conseiller départemental c'est être
élus de l'institution qui vient au plus
proche des personnes vulnérables
on le sait les personnes âgées les
personnes handicapées la station des
jeunes et et c'est l'institution qui est
donc chef de file en matière
d'accompagnement social et à travers
tous ces périodes que nous connaissons
période difficile de créer sanitaires
demain de crise économique puis de crise
sociale il était évident aujourd'hui que
le conseil départemental se trouve je
dirais aux un certain croisement dans la
vie des réunionnaises et des réunionnais
et nous devons être acteur aux côtés de
notre population